[Music]
I'm William Dennis a product major on
google kubernetes engine I'm going to
cover three broad topics today the first
is y cubed is the second is best
practices for application deployment on
de kubernetes and lastly planning for
growth so let's get started with why
kubernetes and I guess that helps to
actually explain what communities is for
those not familiar so people call
kubernetes a container Orchestrator
which is really just a fancy way of
saying that it manages your containers
the application developer is responsible
for container izing their application
and describing properties of that
application like the memory and CPU
requirements and then an operator is
responsible for deploying that
application to the cluster which could
actually be the same person kubernetes
then takes that and manages all the kind
of heavy lifting for you so it basically
just works out where to put those
containers very simplified overview what
makes it popular well one of the top
reasons is that you get the language
flexibility of containers so there's no
requirement of what language you're
using or what versions of the libraries
or anything like that there's less
vendor locking with kubernetes
kubernetes is based on open source and
in fact Google runs certified
communities this is a version that's
been certified by the cloud native
computing foundation using a
certification program that actually I
participated in creating and there are
about 50 other vendors that are also
offering certified communities so you
can be assured that whatever you do you
but it is you can you can run it in a
number of different places it's also
highly resource optimized so you can
really pack a lot of containers on the
same pool of computer resources you can
build your own pipelines so let's say if
you have a particular opinion on how you
want to deploy software you want like a
blue-green type deployment or whatever
preference you have for deploying things
I guarantee there's a way you can do it
on kubernetes there are also just tons
of open source add-ons so because the
project is open source there's this
massive community and you get all these
great open source add-ons you name it
there's probably an open source add-on
that can they can help you and finally
at least you deploy a whole bunch of
different types of applications beyond
just like a 12 factor stateless
application so I mentioned at the outset
that containers is one of the most
important reasons maybe it's worth just
giving a quick recap on why containers
are so good so if we look back at how
you might have deployed multiple
applications on a single machine in the
past it probably would have looked like
the one on the left there with a share
machine we have a whole bunch of
different apps sitting on the one
machine
there was no isolation between the apps
so if one of them started using all the
resources it would impact all of the
apps there were common shared libraries
between them so it's a real pain if you
had to have like a different version of
the dependencies then we moved to VMs
where you've got some isolation between
the apps and you had isolation in the
sense that there was no common libraries
but it was a lot more expensive and
inefficient because the kernels getting
duplicated in each of those VMs
which finally brings us to containers
which kind of gives you the isolation
properties of VMs particularly when you
add in things like gee visor some new
open source that Google released a month
ago a couple of months ago now you get
the same property of the VM and that
libraries are not shared but there's a
lot less overhead and we should know
because Google's actually been running
containers in production for over 12
years and for about three years prior to
that we were heavily developing this
technology including contributing some
of the underpinnings like C groups to
Linux so back to kubernetes communities
is a workload level abstraction and what
I mean by that is that you describe your
resources in terms of the workload like
I want ten of container a and I want 20
of container B I want them grouped
together on adjacent nodes or I want
them to spread far around the world or
maybe something different maybe I want
to render a movie and I want to render
that one frame at a time as a batch job
and I want to use the cheapest compute
resource available so like the
preemptable vm it's a worker level
abstraction so you just define those
workloads and its job is to handle that
for you I believe it sits at the ideal
level of abstraction as well so it
doesn't go super low level such that you
have to manage like individual machines
but it's not super high level either in
the in the sense that it doesn't tell
you how to design your apps it really
sits nicely in the middle to me this
contrasts with the kind of platformers
of service or the past
we're delays were a little bit blended
the application and the past layer that
sits on top of the ayahs the
infrastructure as a service and you can
see this because the pass is actually
like typically like changing some code
in the application this can be very
convenient because it can do helpful
things for you but could but it can also
constrain you kubernetes I think has a
very nice layer separation keeping all
these concerns quite separate and the
main point about kubernetes I think is
that it really prioritizes making hard
tasks possible over simple tasks easier
so I guarantee you if you have a task
and it's already quite easy and you want
to make it easier you can probably find
a way to do that there's going to be
someone that can help you make it even
easier and why not you know it's always
good to optimize things but you have to
ask yourself I think am I actually
making the hard tasks harder by pursuing
this route urbanize people probably
won't say that it makes simple tasks
easier I would say it doesn't make
simple tasks particularly hard but where
it really excels is that you can capture
just a broad range of things and do it
fairly in a fairly streamlined way and
why kubernetes engine so this is google
kubernetes engine the hosted product
that runs kubernetes that my team
manages it's actually the same team that
writes and contributes the majority of
the open source that brings you cuban
notice engine so if you're looking for
people that have real expertise in
communities
definitely take a look at at our product
here and maybe more important in the
software i think is the attitude that we
have to open-source so this is a quote
from Eric Brewer at the keynote last
year where he said we're gonna be the
open cloud we're gonna give you the
freedom to join and to leave and I'll
take my chances and I think this really
aligns us with your objectives as well
by making it so easy for you to come and
leave we're incentivized to make it as
good as possible so that you stay
because it's good not because you're
locked in so I think there are
objectives get all quite well aligned so
before I jump into a demo let me cover a
few key kubernetes concepts to help
explain the demo
I covered containers already pod in
communities there's the object called a
pod which is actually just a collection
of containers it could be one or many
the reason we have a pod this is the
smallest schedulable unit in kubernetes
and the reason we have a pod is so that
if you have like tightly coupled
containers that need to be deployed
together you can represent them like
this but often a pod will just be one
container then we have nodes those are
just a way of saying machines we call it
nodes because they can either be a VM or
it could be bare metal as you saw at the
keynote yesterday morning GK now works
on prem so this will be more and more
common and then there's a deployment the
deployment is the real driver in
kubernetes it's a statement of the
desired number of pods that you want to
be running so in this example we have
deployment a which says I want to of pod
a and we have deployment B that says I
want one of my pod kubernetes what uses
what's called an operator pattern where
he will observe this state of the
cluster it will look at what you have
specified the desired state and we'll
drive that observe state to the desired
state for you so in this case the user
has said I want to of pod a and one of
pod be and that is what cubanos is
observing but what would happen if that
node became unhealthy
well kubernetes would observe that
there's actually now only one of pod a
and none of pod B it would redeploy
those pods onto a node that that was
fine after which the observe state again
matches the desired state and everything
is right in the world
that's deployment last one I want to
cover is service so a service is really
just a group of identical pods that
hosts like an HTTP service or TCP
service or whatever you're trying to
provide it's just a way of collecting
all the pods and addressing them
together okay so with that let me talk a
little bit now about how to actually
deploy things into kubernetes and it all
starts by docker izing and deploying to
kubernetes let's switch to the demo
okay so I have a very simple nodejs up
here and I added a ten-second
startup time for reasons that'll be
apparent in a moment it's just to
emulate an app that takes a little while
to boot let's take a look at this app
it's extremely simple
so that's running not in containers just
running on my machine let's take this
app put it into Google communities
engine and put it into a container so I
mean I can build this locally with the
docker build command but actually the
best practice is to use a cloud build
tool because you don't know if maybe I
had some changed files here on my
machine that weren't in version control
I probably don't want those changes
going into production without getting
code reviewed so let's not deploy that
container I built locally let's set up a
cloud build environment to use cloud
build I'll need a source repo probably
should pick the project
okay I'm gonna create the repo called
next demo by the way that thing that
just happened that was me just tapping
the security key
it just helps keep everything safe a
little second factor device so a
repository that's crazy is called next
demo and I'm gonna push the code up okay
so while that's getting pushed up let me
go to cloud builder now and I'm gonna
create a build trigger that's gonna
build this code into a container so
we'll pick Google source repository you
can also connect this to a bit bucket
and get up I'm gonna pick that repo that
I just created and I'm literally going
to leave everything as the default so we
want to build this from a docker file
that'll looks good let's just create the
trigger so normally this would be
triggered when I push code I'm just
gonna trigger it manually so you can see
what happens and we should see here we
go okay so that container is now
building in the cloud very similar to
when I just built it then wait for that
to finish only takes a few seconds just
running my npm install there is a little
node app and we're done all right so
let's get this into kubernetes engine so
I'll go over to cuba nice engine and I'm
gonna pick the my app cluster that I
created earlier and I'm gonna click this
deploy button here there's kind of a
simplest way to get started by the way
I'm gonna select the container that I
just built I'm gonna give it a name
let's call it hello next and deploy
and that's basically it quite simple
there is one more thing I need to do I
need to actually expose this service so
that we can actually view this online so
because my container was running port
8080 I'm gonna target port 8080 from
port 80 I'm gonna pick the service type
load balancer so that you can all take a
look and click expose so if I now go to
the services tab there you can see that
there's one service here which is
creating endpoints since that takes a
minute or so because that IP address
space goes to get broadcast to every
point of presence that Google has around
the world I'm just gonna look at this
one that I created oil and that is the
application that I just demonstrated
locally now running in the cloud pretty
straightforward right let's go back to
the slides
all right but one of the advantages of
kubernetes
is that it can really help you automate
a whole bunch of different things in
your cluster for all these great things
to actually work though you need to
actually give it some hints and let it
know how it can help you one of the most
important things that you need to
specify are these liveness and readiness
checks
these are probes that run at frequent
intervals checking the consistency of
the container they look very similar but
they have an important difference so the
liveness check is intended to just check
the integrity of the container is the
container running and if the container
actually crashes kubernetes is smart
enough to restart it but if your
application hangs kubernetes doesn't
know if if the application hung or if
it's running just fine so this is why
you need to have a probe and that's what
the liveness probe is for is my
container just operating readiness is a
slightly different check although it
uses the same function where you
indicate to communities that the
container is ready to receive traffic so
it's a slightly different state to
whether it's actually running your
container may have an external
dependency like on clouds SQL in which
case you could be alive and running but
it may not have that database connection
yet in which cases it would pass the
liveness check but not the readiness
check perhaps a diagram would help
so we have the liveness probe that goes
just from the control plane to the
container and a readiness probe that
goes to the container and the external
dependencies the reason why you'd want
to mix these two is that you communities
will actually reboot the container if it
doesn't respond to the liveness probe so
if your liveness probe is dependent on
an external service which goes down you
don't actually necessarily want your
container to restart at that moment
that's why we separate it of course
maybe you do after a while because maybe
there's something kind of funky with
that connection so you can configure the
readiness probe to still restart your
container but typically at a at a slower
pace so that you don't turn the
containers there are three options for
these probes one is a command where
communities will use the exit status the
second is a tcp port where it will just
try and open a socket if the socket
opens that everything's good and the
third one is an HTTP request where it
will make an HTTP request and look at
the HTTP response code it's the third
one that I'm going to demo today so
let's switch back to the demo all right
and first up I'm actually going to show
you what happens if you don't have a
radiance check so to do that I'm just
gonna have a little while loop here
that's just going to go while true I'm
gonna curl that endpoint that I just
created so you can see it's just
printing out this is app that I created
and the current time so that you can see
that there's actually something changing
alright let's add something to this
all right I'm gonna just add a little
smiley face here so it's just some
change that we can do it alright we're
gonna push this up and as you know
already this is going to build a
container for me so I'm gonna deploy
that container but before I do just to
make the demo run a little better I'm
gonna take a look at my deployment here
and I'm just gonna remove the app that I
deployed actual has an automatic
horizontal pod all the scale which I
don't want for this demo but I will be
showing you later so if you're not okay
so now that we're ready to go let's see
if that container was built looks like
it was I'll grab the new container name
go back to cubed in this engine and this
is also showing you how to update your
app so I'm just going to do a rolling
update here I'm going to paste in the
new container image click update and
let's switch over and see what happens
so you notice there's a few errors on
the top right here those errors are
happening because as I mentioned this
particular container has a ten-second
boot time so while it was booting the
because we didn't give it a readiness
check all the containers were receiving
traffic even the ones that weren't ready
that's why you'll see a bunch of errors
there so let's go back to here and add a
readiness check
so this is what the readiness check
looks like I'll explain what it all
means in a second so below the container
in the configuration by adding a
readiness probe we're saying the failure
threshold is 3 so if this probe fails
three times assume that there's a
problem that the container needs to be
restarted we'll do an HTTP GET request
with an initial startup delay of three
seconds we'll run that every three
seconds and if it succeeds once we're
going to count that as a success so
let's save that nope
I'm just gonna force update that okay
looks like I've got a few terminating
pods here that I take a little bit of
time so let me update the app while we
wait for that and so I can demo what the
rollout looks like when you have a
readiness check
okay go back to cloud builder same
process think we're in a good state now
so let's roll this out and as we do
let's observe what happens so this time
oh by the way we're still waiting for
the image to be built so that's actually
building in the background I was a
little bit quick there one of the good
things about communities as you see
where it says image pull back off
it's actually smart enough not to try
and boot the container that doesn't
exist yet so it's actually going to keep
retrying that which is pretty neat
and it just got it and if you observe
here where it says ready you can notice
that it's actually not ready yet and
we're still routing traffic to the
previous container once that flips over
to ready now you can see that it's
flipping between the two different
expressions they're both both containers
receiving traffic then it's going to
terminate the old container and route
all the traffic to that one so unlike
previously when there was an error state
as traffic got routed token haze they
weren't ready once you have the
readiness check that that error doesn't
happen and you have a very smooth update
that's what makes readiness checks so
important all right back to the slides
please
all right now you may have seen that I
was using a lot of UI there and I was
kind of just like patching the
configuration fairly willy-nilly maybe
it doesn't surprise you that that is not
the production best practice so let's
talk a little bit about what is so as
I've covered communities is built on a
declarative style architecture where you
declare the state that you want and it
drives that observed state to the state
that you declare what this means is that
you end up with a lot of different
configuration files the workloads and
the services are all specified with
configuration so what do you do with all
that configuration well at Google we've
actually had this problem for quite some
time so we have a fairly good experience
on how to deal with this this is a quote
from the Google sre the site reliability
engineering book which you can read
online for free and it says that at
Google all configuration scheme
that we use for storing this convey
involves during that configuration our
primary source code repository and
enforcing a strict code review
requirement that is the same code review
requirement for configuration as for
code the benefits of this model so if
you're storing configuration in get
along with the code or in a separate git
repo is you get kind of all the benefits
that you get with code with storing code
in version control you get rollbacks
so if you rolled out the wrong release
you can just roll back the configuration
and I will effectively rollback that
release you get versioning and
auditability if someone asks you hey
what version of our code was running at
9:00 a.m. on Monday well if you're just
patching it by hand you probably don't
know but if everything is stored in and
get you can just look back through the
the commit history and see what was
running at exactly that time you can
also utilize code reviews so you can try
and avoid that situation where someone
fat-fingers the the replica count down
to one by accident
takes down the service disaster recovery
so while this is not the primary mode of
making your communities application
highly available in kubernetes we
support regional clusters and a whole
bunch of different things is of course
good to have that configuration stored
in version control as a backup and
finally whatever identity and
authorization model you have on your
code you can apply that to the
configuration as well so you could
potentially restrict it to you know an
SRE type role if you wanted to so what
does that look like you know in a git
kubernetes world this was just one
pattern of one way to do it but it's
kind of the one I recommend where you
would have like one configuration
repository per app so in this example
there are two repos at the top there one
for the app foo one for the app bar and
then use branches for each environment
of the app so the master branch likely
Maps to production you can have a
staging branch and these branches of
configuration map one two one two
namespaces in kubernetes the advantage
of that is that you don't have to change
the object name if you have an app
called foo deployment you don't have to
call it food deployment staging you can
just call it food deployment because
you're going to deploy it into a
namespace
it's up to you if you want to run this
on two clusters or one so I've just
shown here just for examples sake having
two different clusters and a bunch of
different namespaces that part's totally
up to you how do you get from the state
though that I was demoing into this new
kind of more production grade system
well fortunately it's pretty easy you
can just extract all the configuration
resources that you had so far using this
command cube CTL get resource - - oh
yeah Mille once you've done that you can
also set up some very nice things like
continuous deployment so we have a
product cloud build I demoed it just
showing building the container but you
can actually use it to roll out the
config change as well and all you need
is this very simple configuration file
it basically says I want to use the cube
CTL task I want to run the command at
the bottom which is applied - F dot
which just means apply the current
directory of kind of config and I'll
give it to environment variables so it
knows where to run that let's switch to
the demo and I'll show how I can migrate
this app that I've created into that new
environment first let's look at the
deployment objects we have one
deployment object hello next that I
created in the UI I'm gonna download the
config for that I'm gonna use the export
come on here as well so that it kind of
skips some extra config that I don't
really need okay and that's what it
looks like if you saw briefly before
that's the the same conflict that I was
editing on the website I mentioned that
we can hook this up to cloud build so
let's take a look at how that will work
to use cloud builder once again I'm
going to create another source
repository this one I'll call next demo
config
I'll go to cloudbuilt and again go to
the build triggers I'll add a new
trigger again on the Google Cloud source
repository
we'll pick here the config one but
instead of using the docker file what
I'm going to do is I'm going to point
this at the cloud build config file
which is also in this directory which I
can just show you it's the same file
that I had up on the slide it's in a
subdirectory so that's all one one
change we're just going to point this at
the cloud build file and we're gonna
create that trigger which will sit
alongside the code contained a building
trigger that I have alright so let's get
this in push that up and we'll take a
look at what happens in the build
history so you can see that just like we
were building the container before we're
now actually executing this config build
instead of building a container it's
actually applying this is running this
come on which is cube see tail apply
dash F dot basically it's just going to
roll out all that config in that git
repo onto the cluster so let's demo an
app update using continuous deployment
change that one more time
and this time I'm not going to use the
UI because I know what the image is
going to be named based on the char
let me just look at that and here in my
config and I open that up and I'm going
to edit here the container image and I'm
just gonna paste in the new char because
I know that container builder is going
to create a container with that name so
I don't have to go back to the UI
anymore alright this time let's just
observe what happens so in theory this
should in a few seconds pick up that
commit automatically and start rolling
it out into the cluster let's get my
little curl while loop backup running
yes there we go so Google cloud build
picked up the change has applied the
change where once again waiting for that
readiness check to pass very soon on the
right you're gonna see that change I
just made get rolled out we're splitting
the traffic I'm going to terminate the
old container in just a moment so that
is kind of the start of a you know
proper production grade pipeline on GK
obviously you can take this a lot
further the team also has various
different ways of doing this we have a
product called spinnaker which is fairly
advanced and we have some partners in
this space like get lab we've works code
fresh but that's just one way to do it
back to the slides please
so of course it goes without saying I
think but I'll say it anyway once you
move to configuration is code
don't go editing the configuration are
applying it outside of version control
so don't be doing what I was doing
before in the UI once you move into this
system because then of course you're
violating the constraint that everything
went through a code review right okay so
what we covered we've covered how to
configure your cluster so that
kubernetes knows when your application
is running when it's ready we've talked
about how to export that configuration
and get it into a production grade or
close to production grade pipeline
there's a couple more things that you
need to do to help communities help you
and one of those is telling it what
resources you need for your container so
this comes in two forms
kind of like the probes before but they
all again they have two very specific
requirements the requests is how you
reserve resources for your pod and
limits constrain how many resources your
pod can use so if you request all the
resources in the cluster then then the
scheduler will actually stop scheduling
new containers whereas limits just
restrain your container I think a
diagram is probably more helpful here
this was showing one VM and all of the
resource allocation of that VM we have
container a that requested 20% of one
CPU container B that requested 50%
container C that requested 20 and then
let's look at what's actually being used
so that was just the resource allocation
but it's not actually it doesn't
actually restrain what the container can
use so here we have containers C using a
lot more than it said it would
we have container B using a bit less
than it said and a using bit less as
well this is actually really good
because this means that you're not
wasting those resources even though they
were allocated to container B container
C can use them as long as container B
isn't so it's kind of like a way of
guaranteeing a minimum amount of
resources without actually constraining
the maximum now if you do want to
constrain the maximum then you can set a
limit as well so I could have limited
container C here to 25% in which case it
won't it won't go over that amount what
this means though is that if you have a
container like
here contain adi that is requesting 20%
it's actually not going to get scheduled
so even though the cpu does have 20%
capacity available because it wasn't
allocated it's not going to get
scheduled this is how you set it up in
the deployment so you just put this in
pretty much exactly what I did with the
probes I'm not going to demo that one
but it's fairly easy to set up and you
can look at Google stack driver to see
what resources your pods are currently
using in order to set to kind of get
good values for this obviously you want
to put the request kind of somewhere
above the minimum that you need but
obviously you know don't make it don't
make it excessive don't make it too high
because you also kind of want to catch
cases where you might have a memory leak
that's where the limit can come in handy
and you're just like a limit the
container at a certain amount so that
cumin has already started if it ever
uses too much memory another thing to
consider when you set the limits and the
requests on the container is how many
Forks processes you want actually inside
that container so this obviously affects
the memory and the CPU usage before
kubernetes before containers it was
generally pretty good practice to have a
lot of concurrency in each version of
your app because it was such a pain to
deploy the app you wanted to make that
up highly concurrent but in kubernetes
it's very easy to create multiple
replicas of that app such that you don't
have to have a huge amount of
concurrency within the app so what's
what's the right balance though I tend
to think about two or three forked
processors per container is about the
right amount because you do get some
memory savings by just forking the
process and making it internally a
little bit concurrent but the advantage
of having so many replicas is that if
one of them were to crash then you
haven't removed all the capacity whereas
if you had kind of like only two
replicas and a huge amount of
concurrency inside them one of them
going away would be quite problematic
kind of the same trade-off for machines
so larger machines do offer slightly
greater efficiency with kubernetes you
can kind of pack more containers in
there's less wastage but of course more
machines gives you more availability so
kind of the same but as before with more
replicas giving you more availability so
again just balancing
to trade offs of machine size and
machine count to get your desired
availability goal and what about rapid
iteration so you know one of the nice
things about not using containers is
that I could just go node server Tijs
whenever I wanted bring up that
application it was really
straightforward so for communities we
have a tool called scaffold that aims to
give you that kind of quick iteration
that you're used to while still using
kubernetes scaffold observes your
directory of configuration code and
whenever something changes its going to
redeploy your app to communities so you
can very quickly see any changes you
make deployed right so that was about
some best practices of how to describe
your application to communities in a way
that it can help you kind of keep
everything running for you it can
restart the container if there's a
problem it can split the traffic
accordingly
what about growth though what about
planning for growth so this is some
anyway where kubernetes engine really
excels actually we have three kind of
world-class automation tools that we
offer as part of communities engine
the first is cluster auto scaling so
when you schedule a container and there
are not enough resources the cluster
autoscaler can automatically provision
more resources to handle those extra
replicas but perhaps as importantly it
can also remove resources that are not
being used here at Google we don't want
you to pay for compute resources that
you don't need so will actually help you
scale it back in the quiet times to save
money the second one is no order appear
so occasionally VMs can become unhealthy
node order appear is constantly watching
with the VMS just as kubernetes is
watching your containers and it's going
to replace any vm's that have a problem
the last one is node order upgrade so as
you've probably seen from the last
couple of years of news there's a lot of
vulnerabilities that the world discovers
and releases and you probably don't to
stay up late at night worrying about
this so if you turn on node auto upgrade
will keep you up to date and will apply
all these patches to communities
right onto the nodes for you and these
three features are actually to the best
of my knowledge not available in other
clouds these are very much specific to
Google and kind of what makes I think
kubernetes engine just such an amazing
product to really take advantage of
these things though you actually also
need to Auto scale the workload so you
need some way of detecting when there
are more users coming than what you can
serve and automatically adding replicas
of your pod to handle them for that what
we recommend is using requests per
second metrics again this is kind of
like a best-in-class thing to do you can
use CPU and memory usage as a proxy to
scale up your your container so for
example you could say if my container is
like running really hot and he's using
like 90% of the CPU add another one but
not every application is CPU bound in
fact that's fairly uncommon it's often
there's like a queue length is often a
request per second that the app can
handle so on kuben of this engine we
make this actually fairly easy for you
to set up in conjunction with stack
driver monitoring we have a kubernetes
horizontal pod autoscaler component that
can read the request per second metric
from stack driver that's written to
stack driver from the HTTP load balancer
such that when new users arrive we can
automatically provision more containers
to handle the increase in requests per
second from those users so what you do
is you measure how many requests per
second can your application handle just
as you measured how much ram and how
much CPU are used you can it's fairly
easy to measure how many requests what
the throughput is of your application
and then you can just say to communities
look I want each of the replicas to have
you know a maximum of 6 say 6 requests
per second or 100 or whatever it is
setting up a horizontal pod autoscaler
is really straightforward you just have
one more piece of confit I know Kuban is
is all about the config there's really
only two lines that matter there - it's
the ones are highlighted in blue and
that is my metric is the request count
coming from the load balancer and my
target value per container in this case
for this example is going to be sick
request per second I want to have one
container running for every six requests
per second let's switch over to a demo
and I'll show that in action
alright so at the bottom right there I
have a stack driver monitoring showing
the requests per second on this service
and you can see there's kind of like you
know just under two requests per second
happening right now let me add a couple
of while loops to generate some load on
this that should be about 20 RPS I
believe after about 30 seconds to 60
seconds that that RPS should show up in
stack driver and we'll see if the
cluster reacts to handling I'm going to
set some watches here so gonna watch how
many replicas we have that container how
many nodes we have and for good measure
I can also watch the status of my
horizontal pod autoscaler now as this
takes a few seconds to show up I'm
actually gonna switch to a video and
show you kind of a 30 minute window of
what happens when a whole bunch of
traffic arrives on this on this example
application but I'll switch back to this
so you know I wasn't cheating later all
right so this is the video I recorded on
Monday exact same demo and here we've
just added an extra five RPS and I'm
just gonna speed up the video a little
bit so you can see in the chart on the
bottom right that the QPS is just about
to arrive
we should clock up there to about eight
or nine and because I set a target of
six RPS per container looks like we're
currently at about seven you can
actually see that quba news has already
scheduled a second container at the top
left there to handle that extra traffic
I'm going to speed up this demo again
and let's try adding another ten QPS of
traffic
and you can see that the ten QBs
registered in stackdriver the horizontal
pod autoscaler successfully scheduled
two more containers but it looks like
there's a problem
so those containers are pending they're
not they're not running yet and the
reason is is that this cluster is
actually out of resources so those
containers are actually stuck in a
pending state well the good news is as I
mentioned kubernetes has a cluster
autoscaler as well so what's going to
happen is gke kubernetes engine is
watching for this state and has realized
that there are pending containers here
that that don't have the capacity to run
and so it's actually automatically
provisioned one more node there you can
see in the in the second from the top
left once that node becomes ready and
let me just play the demo those pending
containers get created and they're now
running and serving traffic alright so
for a bit of fun let me just add another
like twenty QBs and will speed up the
demo quite fast and we'll see what
happens
once again it's scheduled small
containers scheduled some more nodes I
think wrapped about five nodes now and
but I told you that you're gonna save
money as well right so like here I've
simulated a whole bunch of users
arriving you might have been sleeping I
don't know what what was happening could
be the weekend whole bunch of users
arrived and we're successfully served by
your app so they weren't disappointed
they didn't have like a fail character
on the screen they were successfully
served while you were sleeping or on
vacation or whatever but what about
saving your money alright if I drop the
load all the load off here drop it back
to like five QPS let's see what happens
and I'm gonna run the demo a little bit
fast because as with a lot of auto
scaling things they're scaling down is a
little bit more conservative than
scaling up the reason is that it's
typically said that way is that you
don't want to kind of quickly deep
revision resources in case in case the
users come back straightaway so it looks
like we've already deep revision their
pods
in the top left they are no longer
running but we still have some nodes
that are running there that are probably
not needed now that we only have one
container so let's see what happens
and look at that the notes have been
removed deep revision and we're back to
the starting to node cluster so that is
kubernetes horizontal pod auto scaling
using an RPS metric and the cluster
autoscaler
to scale up and down the cluster back to
the slides
okay
so what did I show you the recap is we
looked at readiness and liveliness
probes and how important they were the
importance of defining requests and
limits so that communities knows what
resources that you need the idea that
you should be treating configuration as
code using a CI CD pipeline to deploy
code so that you're not going to
accidentally deploy things that were
just like happen to be sitting on your
machine using us using a CI system means
that you're only going to deploy the
code that was checked in and with a CD
system you're only going to deploy the
configuration that was checked in you
should turn on all the automation
settings of kubernetes engines so you
can just sleep easier at night and then
finally Auto scale using RPS
you
[Music]